if you've been following the overwatch
lakes you might have seen what looks
like some new skins from the next event
well prepare to see a whole lot more
than that I'm Tony in this game spot
news update has been Declassified /
watches next big event is titled
insurrection according to the leaked
trailer from PlayStation France the meat
of this update is a new co-op mission
that takes place seven years in the past
during tracers first outing with the
overwatch squad it's set in a torn up
version of kings row where a bunch of
purple robots are going crazy during the
amna crisis I'd expected to play
similarly to overwatch is Halloween
event junkin Stein's revenge and of
course you can expect a ton of new skins
and victory poses and sprays and a whole
lot more including some sweet Blackwater
outfits for McCree and Genji
insurrection is a limited time event
running from april eleventh through May
first seems like plenty of time if you
want a taste of the world before / watch
as we know it and for more gun-toting
action you can check out our video on
six guns to help you through Mass Effect
Andromeda on insane difficulty
you
[Music]